this is from timcast.com Twitter removes
portion of hateful conduct policy that
prohibited dead naming and misgendering
transgender People based the platform
has prohibited using pronouns matching a
trans person's biological sex since
2018. the policy appears to have been
changed on April 8th an archived version
of the page from April 7th still stated
those rules the last sentence has since
been removed and said the policy now
States the platform prohibits targeting
others with repeated slurs tropes or
other content that intends to degrade or
reinforce negative or harmful
stereotypes about a protected category
I'm just going to say it again
I know I'm the low guy on the totem pole
in this regard but Elon Musk Joe Rogan
me having a follow-up to the Jack Dorsey
the jagata episode we did I think would
be absolutely tremendous uh but I guess
I'm the low guy obviously I'd love to be
sitting in a room with Elon and Joe
Rogan but uh at least I can say that
follow-up I think would be very
important because this was a core
component of it it's so important too
you think about there's this guy Charles
climber who is a trans activist and he's
very far left I think he worked for the
Human Rights Campaign he worked for this
ridiculous group called Catholics for
Choice a pro-abortion Catholic roof yeah
not the most coherent kind of a group
and if the policy were in place that you
couldn't refer to Charles Clymer you
have to call him whatever girl name he
goes by it this would be very convenient
for Charles because he has a bit of a
dodgy past back when he was Charles and
got into some political scandals so if
you're not allowed to refer to Charles
all of a sudden wow how nice all of
these all of these problems and Scandals
go away I Google search away well I
think the other issue with it is where
is the line in what someone is allowed
to identify as and this is a huge
component so uh back in I think 2018 I
was looking at New York City's laws and
they protect by they identify 31 genders
but the law explicitly States infinite
genders exist because it defines gender
expression as self-expression and so
they say that you can't discriminate in
public accommodations based on the
clothing a person wears the name they go
by
and if that's the case what is the legal
limit so I ask a human rights lawyer and
they said well obviously there's a
reasonableness expectation in the law
the assumption is with this law it's if
a person is transgender they're you know
discernably male but wearing a dress you
can't fire them if they're certainly
male but going by the name Susan you
can't fire them and so I asked a a
couple human rights lawyers
if somebody went to Starbucks and um
applied for a job then showed up on day
one in a fursuit and they called
themselves vociferon Herald of the
winter Mists would Starbucks be able to
fire them for this and they said yes of
course that's ridiculous and I said well
why why can't they sue under that very
same law that that is their gender
expression
and what I was told was a judge would
laugh them out of the courtroom and then
I said what if the judge doesn't like
trans people and laughs at the man in a
dress what's the difference and they
didn't have an answer well and you know
the the case that established a lot of
this is that Harris Funeral Home case
from just a few years ago in in which
we're talking about a funeral home here
so the customers at funeral homes are
very very vulnerable they're grieving
their loved ones and there was this dude
who decided that he wants to be a chick
and so he started wearing skirts to work
and the owner of the funeral home said
uh hey man I don't know what you're
getting into but you know you've got to
have some respect for them
this isn't about you man you know this
is about the the people who are mourning
and he sued him went all the way up to
the Supreme Court and and the Supreme
Court decided that that man that man's
sexual fetish was more important than
people's right to mourn respectable but
think about how crazy this is if if you
have a funeral home the issue is not
that we don't like that you're wearing a
dress I mean Celts exist they're similar
in a certain respect but we're talking
about you respecting someone whose loved
one died and there's formal attire
requirements with New York City's law
they've basically abolished uniforms
it says you can't discriminate based on
what someone wears in public combination
so if I show up at Starbucks wearing a
clown costume let's just be reasonable
I'll show up wearing jeans and a t-shirt
and say you can't make me wear those
clothes because those are man clothes
yeah they can't do anything about it the
the the astounding thing however to me
was and this is a honestly a big uh
Revelation for me in understanding law a
judge will laugh a person out of a
courtroom and then I said then there
will be many judges who are going to see
a man wearing a dress and laugh and say
get out of my courtroom this is
ridiculous where's the line and what I
was told is well judge make judges make
those determinations that they're
they're the human interpretation of the
law and then I went interesting the law
doesn't matter the only thing that does
is the culture if the culture tolerates
men and women cross-dressing in public
then the judge will defend it if the
culture tolerates fursuits the judge
will defend it and right now it seems
the fursuit goes over the line but I'd
say in three or four years of course you
will see people in full fursuits at
Starbucks serving your coffee of course
and notice when you say we've now got
the abolition of uniforms this is always
the result of these kind of leftist
policies that specifically focused on
trans right now but all of these leftist
policies is this constant leveling and
lowering down and abolition of Standards
so the answer that people give the
middle ground on the bathrooms is what
you said earlier which is well let's
just all have unisex bathrooms and we'll
just all have individual bathrooms
what's the answer on the sports teams
we'll just have we'll all just have our
own sports teams or something what's the
answer and and so what happens is we all
just become this undifferentiated
androgynous consumer that's all we do
all we are now is is I don't want to
sound like a commie or something but
this is being pushed not just by the
leftist activists it's being pushed by
the entire liberal establishment and by
Corporate America and the whole power
structure which is just to take away all
the ornamentation all the
differentiation all the natural lovely
diversity of life and make us all just a
bunch of blobs to buy a bunch of
hormones and purchase their products and
uniform actually means the same one form
that's what uniform is for is to make
all the same so they're stripping away
the Communist sameness of everything to
create a weird world to then reconfigure
it so that everyone well yeah instead of
having different kinds of uniforms in
different areas of life are different
for men and women now it's literally we
will just be uniform undifferentiated
blobs plugged into our computers and
living in in the metaverse and eating
eyes I think that's absolutely where
we're going uh the the Deep fakery is
getting so Advanced so rapidly
last time I was on Rogan I said I didn't
think it was that big of a deal and I
was so wrong and and so naive because I
was looking at the Modern iterations of
deep fakes and I was just like I'm not
worried about that I didn't stop to
consider the rapid degree of Advance how
long ago was that when you were wrong
this was a year and a half ago year and
a half think about how fast right
so far in six months a year and a half
ago there was like one program that had
accomplished voice manipulation and
there were some goofy videos that were
low-res and I was just like I'm not
worried about this
and then within a year and a half it
Advanced the point where I I was on
Instagram
and I saw a Rogan clip and it's Joe
advertising some uh I think it was like
a I think it was penis growth or
something like that some weird like
testosterone booster thing and uh I was
like whoa it was if you if you if you
watched it you're like that's a d fake
if you were just passing through you
might not have noticed and that's when I
was like oh man now we have that 11 Labs
website where you can take 30 seconds of
anyone talking drop it in and you can
make them say whatever you want now I'm
like imagine what it's going to be like
in a year
there is going to be a defect of Donald
Trump giving a speech that looks
completely real he will say something
kind of bad but not really that bad but
bad enough to lose votes and no matter
what anyone says the left will believe
it I wonder if it'll get to the point
where there will be two presidents
according to everyone and no one will
know which one's the real one and which
one's the fake that's a good point
because yes because someone will make a
deep fake clip of CNN and put it on
Twitter by a verification and then it'll
be Don Lemon saying Donald Trump has
been re-elected this 2024 and then
people are going to see the clips and
they're going to believe it I mean
that's gonna happen this AI stuff is
actually the end of society I know
people like to claim that all sorts of
advancements and Innovations are the end
of society this one actually is because
it impels people to just Retreat into
themselves for everything so now we will
Retreat into our own fantasies for art
it makes great art so the art that I put
up on my walls I can just type it into
mid-journey or any of them and get a
beautiful piece of art it will you'll be
able to create these these deep fakes of
video and audio it's obviously going to
be applied to porn I assume it actually
probably already is being applied to
porn is it yeah and I'm sure in the
future I'm sure it will be and so people
will have no reason to engage in reality
because one you won't have any common
referent to talk about you'll just have
I'll have my video of trump and you'll
have your video of trump and we'll both
have made them up we we I'll have my
fantasy that I'm living in be it uh
personal be it uh entertainment be it be
it sex be it anything and we'll all just
we'll all just be living in our pods
plugged into our own fantasies that is
the end of community the only thing I
can think that would change that or one
of the things is if the power goes out
and I don't want the power to go out but
if it did then the artificial
intelligence would die I'm not laughing
at you I'm sorry but but there's ways to
make potential electricity that's why
solar wind geothermal not tapping the
vacuum I mean it's
because they want to create my my pitch
I actually pitched this uh half pitched
it to you guys of the daily wire an idea
for a show where I'll try and give the
super simple version
it takes place in a world that's like
human civilizations collapse there's
only one city left and it's people it's
like the year 2130 technology is
comparable to it to what it is now a
conflict emerges between very thin tall
humanoid beings and white jumpsuits with
chrome heads who can shoot lasers humans
fight
no one knows how civilization collapsed
but they assume these creatures must
have wiped out the planet become some
kind of aliens and then in the final
episode of the Season or whatever you
know there's a fight and then someone
hits like a magnet a crane release which
drops a boulder or car onto one of these
creatures and crushes it disabling its
force fields they pull the Chrome helmet
off and oh it's a human and the reveal
is that Society didn't collapse it
migrated underground into pods where
humans all Network themselves with
norlinks into a virtual world and the
reason why the last city was unaware of
what happened to humanity is the news
didn't stop news was still being written
but it migrated my example is if someone
came from the year 1900 to this time
period they'd immediately be like get me
a newspaper so I can learn about what's
happening in the world and then they
would find that newspaper slowly started
to disappear if they if if someone from
the 1900s jumped 200 years in the future
and then just try to take a look at
history based on their understanding of
how to look their history they would be
like newspapers ceased to exist in the
year 2075 5 history was gone we have no
idea what happened humans no I just went
online so my my idea for this show is
there will be some humans who never
migrate and they will not have access to
the the metaverse historical archive so
to them they'll just like their their
great grandchildren will be like we
don't know exactly what happened but
some kind of collapse happened and we
have no access we just find these old
records these old websites and stuff and
servers we try to boot up and figure out
where where where they all went the
problem for those metaverse records
though is that when everything is
digital you can just constantly change
the records this is the one of the
Prophecies of 1984. and that's actually
a component like this show would be
fantastic because the people who live in
the metaverse would have a warped view
of reality because there would be
oligarchs who rewrite history but then
the people who live in the real world
with the physical unalterable will like
meet one of these people in the
metaverse and be like look at these
archives that we've brought and they're
like that's not history and they'll pull
up Wikipedia to show history and it'll
be last edited yesterday and they'll be
like this book hasn't been re-edited in
300 years this is all very scary but I
think what Mark Zuckerberg is trying to
sell is like what if you had Zoom
meetings but you were an octopus
and I'm just like I don't know what to
do with this information well Ian
mentioned earlier like you could
identify as a carrot you know yeah like
you're gonna you're gonna go you're
gonna be in the metaverse on on Tinder
and you're gonna be like a carrot a dog
a toaster a a VW
oh a person swipe from the person even
that gets back to the trans thing like
everything else today which is that in
the metaverse did you see Mark
Zuckerberg cut everyone off at the navel
so initially
they kept sexually harassing each other
so they just cut their legs off is that
what happened yeah on the beta testing
they kept pinching each other and things
they had to chop off their sacks just
again just don't take away their legs it
is you're I think you brought that the
word trans because of the transhumanism
movement well that's what it's all about
ultimately and the word says is from the
mathematical term trans and sis
Alpine Gall trans Alpine golf the
billionaires are all super into the
transhumanist stuff and because they're
evil they don't want to die
and that's an incredibly dark impulse
and that's why they're kind of getting
behind all the transgenderous stuff
because yeah that's totally true mental
step it's a lot of these guys are pretty
intelligent but sometimes intelligent
people are just the dumbest people on
Earth for all of human history really
rich selfish people have tried to figure
out how to live forever and we're living
in such a stupid time that we're this
has been going on for all of history and
people now go online and they say wow
you know we're really close to living
forever this time we've almost figured
it out spoiler alert they're not going
to figure it out that's not a real thing
you're just gonna kill a bunch of people
in the process yes trying to find out
you're going to kill a bunch of people
you're going to cause all sorts of havoc
and it's that same Lie from the Garden
of Eden which is the lie that ye shall
be as Gods Ferrari refers to this as
homo Deus that we're now going to take
control over the future of humanity and
you think okay good luck buddy I mean
unfortunately it's going to cause lots
of problems in the short term but it
ain't gonna work man I think we need to
get the daily wire crew we we might have
to force them to watch Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood it's an anime and
uh but I'll just spoil it for you right
now to explain I was just about to watch
it
Attack on Titan is also really good uh
and I'll tell you why full metal uh
Alchemist Brotherhood is about a
basically this entity that wants to
sacrifice humans to become immortal to
to to ascend to a higher plane and so
it's just government conspiracy to
murder people and sacrifice them so uh
that I think is interesting there's
something like Matt Walsh said about
like not watching anime and then there
was like a backlash from people like no
there's some good stories here and
Attack on Titan is about
ancestral crimes and how certain races
of people should be held criminally
responsible for things their answers to
thousands of years ago so that's they're
interesting stories that I think yeah
what the Italians did those poor
Etruscans those poor Etruscans oh yeah I
mean don't get me started dude Etruscans
let's rock and roll that's where that's
the Romans took credit for all that
stuff
guns actually are where it's at I found
I was reading the sub stack of Pope head
the other day great sub stack and I saw
this quote from Seneca the philosopher
Seneca and it was about the difference
between the Romans and the Etruscans and
Seneca said the difference between us
Romans and those Etruscans is the the
Romans look at Clouds creating rain and
they say Okay Natural Forces came
together and they put the clouds and
then the rain came and then here's some
meaning that we could infer from that
but those Etruscans who attribute
everything to the Divine they believe
that the gods wanted to express meaning
and so they pushed the clouds together
and had the rainfall and the thing is
the Etruscans were totally right have
you ever moved clouds with your magnetic
field I have not I am not a God you can
oh you are well it's flowing through you
you utilize the magnetic fields I think
you're wrong I think my field is a
little off we talked with Alex Jones
about this and uh you you weren't in the
room though but I could hear uh I could
hear the screaming from Ian downstairs
yeah Alex so Ian likes talking about
magnetic fields all the time but Alex
Jones actually mentioned that they did
experiments and found there is some kind
of energy around all of us moving
through us that it's it's uncontrollable
that uh I I don't know exactly how he
described it I was basically saying it
it does connect all of us in some way
but you can't control it just because
something hasn't been controlled doesn't
mean it can't be that's an important
differential you know what I think
I should say you know to hypothesize
sometimes that if there really is this
connection to the the greater or
whatever that people probably don't all
have the exact same connection and
probably to varying degrees some people
I I wonder if the reason why you have
woke NPC type people
and some people who seem to be smarter
more perceptive is simply because
they're called whatever you want third
eye or antenna is more receptive to you
know this kind of energy or whatever
that is to say if you are closed off
from the greater from the spiritual from
whatever prayer is meaningless to you
you don't experience it you haven't
there is nothing Beyond this reality
you're a moist robot and that's all that
there is but if you're someone who has a
greater connection to whatever you want
to call it the spiritual realm or to God
or whatever you're going to understand
and know things and you also can't give
that feeling to a person who doesn't
have that thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time